[Applause]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
we challenge them only show that does it
we challenge our viewers to find a
mistake on our show so far many
challengers not one winner
no one's ever found us making a single
mistake well tonight a fan from Austria
named Qatar Xena Raja when Oscar thinks
she caught a mistake she does it
happened during a spring break sketch we
did a few weeks ago hi Conan I've just
watched a segment of yours for two
spring breakers keep interrupting you
spring break it's the students chance to
take a break from the pressure of school
and really just cut loose go crazy there
is a part where they make you nourish a
baby bird back to health
just give me the baby bird for God's
sake
it's ridiculous okay here we go and I
have noticed a mistake during this part
you usually don't give any liquids to
baby birds because the control can then
very easily get pneumonia and therefore
die in a normal case to get all the
fluids they need through the food fed
better parents if you find a dehydrated
baby bird you should rather take it to
the vet where it gets infusions yeah :
congratulations you have just killed a
baby birds your baby bird killer
bring some Austria well clearly you're
on her side I have to say I love
Catarina I really do i I usually go
after the the you know people that write
in like this but she's got a Nic Cage
pillow and she has positioned it so
perfectly I just I think she's got a
very cool look and she seems like a very
cool person I'm so I'm sorry to tell you
this Qatar Xena but you are dead wrong
yes it's true that most baby birds can't
handle liquids but if you had bothered
to identify the bird I was holding you
would have seen that it was a grey
capped wood Warbler what's so special
about that you may ask well here's a
clip from the acclaimed BBC documentary
planet earth to to explain and then
there is the Curious Case of the grey
captain this Ward Lachie is hungry but
she's not crying out for the world she
wants something else
and homilies just what any other species
would easily choke develop pneumonia and
die is fed in this manner but not the
great caft in fact it must consume food
this way watch as Papa offers a mouthful
of juicy worms instant death this is why
the greedy captain Ravello is extinct in
many parts of Austria specifically the
parts near katarzyna relative enose
courtesy an entire planet curses your
name
and a great
all right the challenge still stands if
you think you've spotted an error on our
show reported it team koco.com / haha I
found an error we will sort it out right
here on the air thank you yes
you